jeudi soir au tri des trois îles et la
fête bat son plein dans cet
établissement
à quelques mètres de là des scènes de
panique des riverains qui s'affolent
le père du jeune homme raconte graffeurs
grammatico l'alchimie de jeu serbe à
bois et puis chaque fois une départ
avait lieu à la manifestation
alors c'est miss et mini core io ka
braqué monde stadio aucun vers le
gardien c'est messi braquer ses missiles
actuellement ces messieurs a fait faux
bond à ses filles à gary kacem et son
fils zachary et bio pour toi
les braqueurs qui se trouvaient au
départ à l'entrée du site ce
rapprochement suite du lieu de la fête
j'ai pas vu exactement
comment ça s'est passé mais d'après les
dires de la sécurité qui était en
extérieur effectivement ils se sont
rapprochés se sont rapprochés
au mont valier en moins de 30 minutes
entre l'agression qui a eu à l'entrée et
la tentative de braquage qui a eu à
l'entrée du quartier
moi aussi j'entends comme vous même
origine étrangère
mais ils étaient cagoulés donc je
pouvais pas et même s'ils n'étaient pas
cagoulés j'aurais pas cru du chignon
plus d'informations à ce niveau qui sont
ces individus qui n'hésite pas à se
servir de leurs armes pour s'emparer du
bien d'autrui
sur sa page facebook christelle
interpelle en anglais les meurtriers de
son fils dylan victime d'une balle au
thorax parce qu'il refusait de céder à
bout tous là encore plusieurs
témoignages font état de la présence d'
agresseurs originaires de l'île voisine
une délinquance d'origine anglophone
serait elle en train de s'étendre dans
le pays
volga plage 3700 habitants ce quartier
informel abrite une importante
communauté cette puce yens ici un
événement a créé l'émoi il ya quelques
jours
rentrée pénétrer chez quelqu'un pointé
une arme sur sa fille de 4 ans
enchaînant sa fille de quatre ans juste
pour s'approprier le clé d'une moto roi
bien qu'il ya un danger qu'est
l'insécurité
l'origine de cette usine je peux pas le
comment je pourrais dire ça c'est comme
j'étais pas sur les lieux quand ça s'est
fait je pense par rapport au langage par
rapport à l action à cause du climat
d'insécurité qui règne dans le quartier
certains habitants décidés depuis cet
incident d'appliquer la loi du talion
s'ils trouvent facile maintenant devenu
son jeune et puis de lui dit de
descendre sous sa moto mille de palu ne
pas lui donner une chance
cette chance c'est de ne pas voir du 10
ans ou c'est de l'utiliser suis
directement donc quelque part les jeunes
sont obligés de chercher un moyen de se
défendre ce que je n'apprécie pas du
tout chaque jeu des plombs mais c'est ce
que cette cette ambiance malsaine ce
climat d'insécurité qui pousse cette
jeune assommé dans le quartier des
jeunes qui ripostent une communauté
pointé du doigt le climat devient
délétère
jean pierre et jean cot sont tous de
sainte luciens avec leur famille ils
habitent la martinique depuis plus d'une
trentaine d'années
cette poussée de violence qui stigmatise
la communauté les inquiète génération
mais compagnie
ils cesseront de nous qui la
raccompagnait il pas bon mais c'est
arrêter baguette a amusé en 2018
huit homicides ont étés consécutifs à
des blessures par balles
sauf que selon les forces de l'ordre
c'est une autre réalité qui s'affiche
la délinquance est en baisse et les
communautés étrangères peu impliqué dans
les affaires judiciaires des étrangers
mis en cause dans des affaires
judiciaires en plus importantes mises en
cause
donc c'est très peu et là je parle
d'étrangers de façon générale toutes
nationalités confondues à saint-lucien
c'est vrai qu ils sont apparus dans des
affaires de vol amer mais assez violent
avec l'utilisation d'armes
or ça ça ça marque les esprits
mais on peut pas dire que les cinq
chiens sont mis en cause dans toutes ces
affaires judiciaires
plus inquiétant encore sur le terrain
les forces de l'autre pointe du doigt
les complicités dont bénéficient les
malfaiteurs étrangers qui sévit sur le
territoire
et c'est tu sais arrivent ici ils sont
hébergés
ils sont cachés qui sont louis ils sont
logés donc ces gens là ils se sont dit
martin qui les aident et les quartiers
dits populaires les plus populaires de
fort de france qui vont aller soulever
aux poudres ont fait rien et c'est puis
cinq à six volets tout mais c'est chez
eux qui a le plus de 5 lucien cacher les
forces de l'ordre sont elle soucieuse
qu'une communauté ne soient pas
stigmatisés
quelle est la part d'implication de
certains complices sur place au coeur de
malaise qui s'installe
la déferlante réseaux sociaux qui
complique l'avancé des enquêtes en cours